hello everyone
it's so wonderful to see you all at this
first convening of the semester
in the virtual world first i hope you
and your families are all staying well
in these unusually challenging times
and as per tradition i want to
acknowledge that we are grateful
to the quinnipiac the waffinger and the
pagosa people
as we stand on their land virtually
keeping in the spirit of recognizing i
would also like to take this opportunity
to thank richard and barbara frankie
for their generosity in establishing the
frankie program in science in the
humanities at yale that enables our
activities
i'm utterly delighted that they
are here this evening i think
they are on uh and they are joining us
from arizona
so um here's a brief preview of coming
attractions for this semester's
activities for the frankie program
before we delve into today's treat
so uh please mark your calendars we've
sent everyone um
save the date dan este will be giving
a talk on um october 15th
and then we have kim stanley robinson um
who will be giving a talk on 18th
november and we have frank snowden
who will be talking to us on december
2nd
so um moving on to today's wonderful
event
i'm absolutely delighted to invite you
all to
our first talk of the season by one of
our own
a very distinguished faculty member
professor valerie hanson
reference professor hanson is a stanley
woodward professor of history and rhys
and her research focus
has been on china before 1600
chinese religious and legal history and
the history of the silk road
she's the uh acclaimed author of several
books
that include previous books that include
the silk road a new history
the open empire and history of china to
1600 negotiating daily life in
traditional china
uh changing gods in medieval china and
voyages in the world his
voyages in world history she has written
numerous essays chapter translated many
scholarly books and
journals she is an authority on
china before 1600 and in particular
has really focused beyond china
in trying to understand transfer
and the history of what we now call
globalization
the history of the process and how
people's coming together
have impacted each other's ways of
thinking
and of the view of the world so during
the pandemic
i usually have been waking up to bbc
radio 4
and a couple of months ago i heard her
voice
which i recognized talking about her
fascinating new book
and was so utterly delighted when she
accepted our invitation to speak
at the frankie program so she recently
published a book
called the year 2000 when globalization
began
which looks at the impact of travelers
who visited
unfamiliar locales the early adventurers
and explorers
and opening up overland and sea routes
that mark the true beginning of
globalization
so she's going to talk to us in this
book she has focused on
travelers before the so-called age of
exploration so these are really the
pioneers
who um in a way join the world together
she a brief biography before i seek the
floor to her
she joined the yale faculty as an
assistant professor of history in 1988
and the breadth of her intellectual
interest is
the course titles that she teaches and i
urge you to go and take a look
um she uh has won many
many honors and is uh recognized for her
uh expertise her most recent honors
include the 2013 gustavranis
international book prize for the best
book on an international subject
by a member of the yale faculty and the
2013
international convention of asia
scholars book prize
reading committee accolade for the best
teaching tool
in the humanities and i'm sure that this
book is going to be gathering accolades
uh it has just come out
so um uh valerie here's
here's to you thank you so much for
coming once again
thank you so much for the invitation and
it's uh strange of course we're all
getting
used to zoom talks i'm still not used to
that and i hope there are no technical
glitches and if there are you'll
forgive me i just realized as prio was
giving me such a generous introduction
that i don't have a slide showing the
book so
i just want to show the book so
so you it exists now um i'd like to
share my screen and uh the talk i'm
giving tonight
is going to be a traditional powerpoint
but we'll take
more breaks than usual
because the uh i went to the
porvu center teaching instruction over
the summer and
one of their pieces of advice was
that the students would get bored after
about 10 minutes
and i figure you're um maybe good for
more than 10 minutes
but uh the anyway there'll be a couple
of breaks uh
during the talk and
i wanted to start with something priya
mentioned actually
about the main claim of the book and
the talk i'm giving tonight about or
this afternoon uh
about when the age of discovery began
and
that most people's and when i say most
people most historians answer
would be 1492 and people would talk
about columbus and
gamma and magellan but um
the contention of the book and of the
talk tonight is that
the vikings the malayo polynesians and
the chinese
were also making long distance ocean
voyages
much earlier around the year 1000 and
the
reason that this is important is that
when the europeans
arrived at different places around the
world
they found societies that already had
sophisticated trading relationships
with each other and the
level of development in those different
places
helped the europeans to penetrate those
existing markets
much more quickly than if they had
arrived at places with a
blank slate uh and um
i wanted to start this is a kind of
classic that
this book by richard evans in defense of
history
uh originally from 1997 uh a manual
that's often taught to be
first-year history graduate students and
even first-year
undergraduates about that presents
definition of what a historical fact is
and
evans explains that historians
use construct arguments that are based
on evidence and the evidence consists
of different facts and so um and he says
that a historical fact is something that
happened in history
and can be verified as such through the
traces that history has left
behind and historians to almost always
focus on written sources
uh but even the early historians like
herodotus and polybius
and people outside of europe like
sumachin in china
traveled to see where the events that
occurred that they wrote about
to talk to people uh polybius is
has a wonderful passage where he goes
and he looks at the snow in the alps
when he's trying to figure out how and
hannibal crossed um the alps with his
elephants
and he looks at he goes and visits the
alps to understand the
conditions of the snow and my talk
tonight is about the
unwritten traces that history has left
behind and how historians
can use them and i wanted to start by
reminding you
where writing was first invented
around the world and the places with the
red circles
um everyone agrees that this is the
independent invention
of writing so among the maya uh in
mexico modern-day mexico
in mesopotamia uh in china and then
um the case of egypt and harap and india
are
debated whether this was independent
origin or they were influenced by
their neighbors but you can see that a
lot of the world is not covered by
these uh circles and if we jump to
the year 1000 which is what i'm talking
about tonight um
that the uh there's a lot of the world
that
is not we don't know about that there
are no written records from
and that's where um some new scientific
techniques
have become very important for telling
us about
the past so
i'm going to start with an example i'm
going to talk about the americas first
where we have some written um sources uh
that were actually oral epochs that were
recorded in old icelandic old norse
um and then confirmed by archaeology and
that's where the chemical residues
will come in uh in terms of american
trade patterns
uh then i'll talk about the pacific and
the
um voyages of the the malayal
polynesians it's a mouthful
but it's just uh a word for the
languages that
the it's the ancestral language of what
becomes modern
malay and modern polynesian
and then i'll close with the chinese
which is home territory for me i am
a chinese historian and for china we
have a lot of written sources
um and so the archaeological finds are
really a supplement to
those written sources
so um i begin with the vikings
and these voyages are described
in the villain sagas which were
transmitted orally
for several centuries before they were
written down in the 13th and 14th
centuries and you can see that the
vikings or the norse travel from
scandinavia
to iceland and from there actually to
greenland
um and then from greenland they go up
um this is uh baffin island in the bay
of baffin
and then uh travel south and land and we
know this because of archaeology
land on the northern tip of newfoundland
um at an archaeological site called
landsaw meadows so
what i was going to say we know this but
when people first read the sagas they
didn't know
where vinland was the sagas talk about a
place
that was very fertile and where wild
grapes
grew and so most people thought that
finland was actually farther south
than um newfoundland uh the
in the middle the early the mid 19th
century
uh one scholar proposed that martha's
vineyard
was actually finland but in 1960
um a two norwegians a
diplomat and his archaeologist wife
arrived at
lance on meadows and they talked to the
locals and asked them if there were
any places that might be a norse
settlement and
the locals brought them to some
collapsed
grass houses made out of sod and wooden
timber and the locals thought that they
were
the homes of native canadians first
nations peoples
but the inkstads began to excavate there
and uh they found evidence
of the norse that um
i would i guess i would say would be
persuasive to other archaeologists
but then they found this bronze cloak
fastening pin
um and this was really
uh a a convincing piece of evidence
because
it ex-matched exactly pins that had been
found
like that in iceland and denmark
and so we call it a diagnostic artifact
if you find such an artifact you
it allows you to diagnose that you're in
the presence of
this x society in this case the norse
and so once the inkstads did their
excavations
there was no question that the norse had
arrived in
northeastern canada
but there was a question about how far
they went oh i was going to say
this is one of their dwellings it was
the biggest
dwelling and this is where they found
other evidence of
the norse they found some uh like a
needle sharpener
and a weight used in spinning uh so
with that tells us that women were with
them and um there was also a boat repair
shed where
there were fragments of iron nails and
the peoples of the americas were working
metal
around the year 1000 but nobody was
working iron so we know
that that was further evidence
confirming the norse
presence
then the question is how far south did
the vikings go
from newfoundland and conventionally
people think that they probably got to
somewhere around maine there's a
viking penny was found in maine
and the evidence now i want to show you
this is definitely speculative this is
not
a hard clad case but it's an interesting
possibility
that they got as far as the maya capital
here
big city the biggest city in the
americas probably about 40 000 when
people lived there
and it was thriving right around the
year one thousand
and um in chichen itza which many of you
have
may have visited this is a famous
building that
people come and visit because uh on the
equinox
this pattern is formed of a like the
shadow of a
dragon's body and then the uh it
the shadow uh ends with the head of the
dragon so
that tells you about the sophisticated
astronomy
that the maya had there's their command
of
astronomical knowledge and um at
chichen itza was a pool called the
sacred cenote
and in the pool the pool was used for
various ritual
offerings and archaeologists have found
things
from other places that allow us to
deduce that there was trade between the
maya
and other places and i'll talk about a
couple of these examples but
basically if archaeologists find
something that they know originates from
a distant place they can posit that that
was either
came to the place that was found either
as a gift
or a trade item and turquoise
is one of the distinctive things that
distinctive items that archaeologists
found at chichen itza
and the it's now possible to use this
secondary iron mass spectrometry to
identify
where turquoise has been an individual
piece of turquoise has been mined
that analysis hasn't been done yet on
the mayan materials
but it's been done on materials in choco
canyon
in new mexico and it turns out that the
peoples of choco
mined their turquoise in a couple of
different places
and in choco canyon which many of you
may also have been to
um there were some pots these are very
typical
uh characteristic pots of
the choco peoples the ancestral
puebloans
and on the bottom of these pots were
some residues
and then when they were analyzed using
this high performance liquid
chromatography
uh the scientists doing the analysis it
was funded by hershey chocolate
uh found the traces of liquid chocolate
and so that allows us to know
that to conclude that there was a trade
between the maya
um their center is on the yucatan
peninsula
they're the only people who are making
chocolate in the americas at this time
and the peoples living in chapel
also in the sacred cenote were these
gold
objects and these have been located as
coming from
either panama or costa rica on the basis
of style
identical artifacts have been found in
those two countries so
that tells us that the maya were trading
um with peoples to the south
as well as to their northwest
uh let's go back to that question about
the vikings and whether or not they got
to the yucatan peninsula um this is a
picture of the temple of the warriors
at chichen itza and um you
are not it's so many people go to the
site now that it's no longer possible
to go in but in the 1920s and 30s
there was a team from the carnegie
institution
in base in washington that went and
recovered
some murals and most of the murals look
like this
this is this scene of invaders from one
village and the people have been painted
in gray the invaders
capturing the people the local people
and you can see that the local people
have stripes on them um that uh so
those are those may be tattooed warrior
marks they may just be
a motif that the artist used to
distinguish between these two groups of
people
i show you this because that's a kind of
typical picture
and this this is unfortunately a
watercolor copy
of an original mural that has now been
destroyed so
all the evidence i'm going to talk about
for the next couple of slides
is secondary it's based it's it's i
think
faithful copies of materials that um
once existed in the 20s and 30s but were
destroyed
after they had been copied by
investigators these are the pictures
that
are quite intriguing because they show
people
these are captives i'll show you how i
know that but
people in this slide you can see that
this person has been thrown
into the water and he's got blonde
hair he also has beads in his hair and
from
other mayan iconography we know that
that's how the mayans
portrayed uh pows by putting
um and this he's floating there and then
this fish
is looks menacingly as if it's about to
uh bite his
wrist these murals none of these murals
um ex the totality they've
i'm showing you details because the uh
they're so damaged
um here's another uh victim who's got
those same be
beads um in his blonde hair
and then here's a victim that uh we can
see more clearly
that he's got the blonde hair and he
also his arms are bound
behind him and he's been thrown into the
water
so the question is whether these might
have been
vikings and the
um and if they were how did they get
there
and um a big part of trying to figure
out who's moving around the world in the
year 1000
and how they moved has to do with these
gyres
the currents that are in the ocean and
so this is a picture of all of the gyres
um
in the world's oceans and then here's a
detail
of um the gyre the north atlantic gyre
and you can see that um if and the red
gyres on the surface of the water the
blue
the blue um uh the blue line
is the deep water under the atlantic and
so
if someone for example had been blown
off course
traveling from greenland to newfoundland
and
the sagas report that multiple ships
were blown off course
um and had connected with the gyre
the gyre could have brought them um
ultimately to
the yucatan peninsula and i i
warned you that this is speculative
right we have no hard
evidence that they arrived but it's
possible the ocean currents would have
facilitated
or would it would have been possible to
be um
uh blown up on shore uh to the yucatan
peninsula
and there's one more piece of evidence
which is i think
well i was gonna say my our late
colleague mike co the great
maya expert he thought this evidence was
more compelling
than the murals of the pows
that this boat um you can see is made
with planks
and they um you can see the outline of
the planks here there's nobody
shown in the this picture this is from a
different building at chichen itza
who is a viking or a possible viking
but the is so he mike co
proposed that this boat was captured
from the vikings and then the maya used
it
and i just give you a comparison so that
you can see uh viking ship uh these are
preserved this is in a museum in norway
um and these have been these were
excavated in the late
uh 1800s and have been preserved
remarkably well
[Music]
and there's also um
a legend that a spanish explorer heard
in 1588
and you know we may or may not believe
this but
the when he was going along the coast of
the yucatan peninsula
he met local peoples who told him about
um 70 morrows so he's writing
in spanish and this meaning black people
presume
i mean presumably from africa they call
their
leader sheke which could be
derived from sheikh um and then chican
is the local word for savannah that
doesn't have anyone living on it
so i mentioned that again just as the
possibility that
people could be washed up on shore and
land on
the yucatan peninsula okay
so let's take our first break
and uh see if you have any questions
and i guess everyone is muted how to how
are we priya help
how are we going to do this you can just
unmute yourself
okay so valerie
we recommend that people type questions
into the chat window
and tai will um read them out so that
all of us can uh hear the question
and we can do it efficiently
um so i i well i i it's
i can ty would you like to read that out
oh yeah sure that's fine if you want to
go ahead um
i'll start with the first one is there
any ethno-botanical evidence
no not that i know of i mean
there's there's ethno-botanical evidence
from lancelot meadows
about um plants that were excavated
there i mean there was a very rigorous
uh excavation done over seven years
atlanta meadows and so
for example they found butternuts there
and butternuts don't grow locally
but they um grow farther south and so
um the archaeologist proposed that the
norse went farther south
got the butternuts and carried them back
to lanson meadows
um the site of chichen itza has a much
more
complicated history excavation his
excavation
um history and uh as far as i know
there's no ethnobotanical evidence
okay
have runes been found anywhere in the
americas and then we'll get back to the
previous question
um the uh
it's funny there um uh there are some
pseudo runes that have been found that
um cop you know uh fake runes um
that have been found but there's no
there's no genuine runes
found in north america
okay
so eske willerslev and forgive me
because i'm probably mispronouncing the
name just published a paper in nature
today on viking genomics from
four over 400 skeletons across europe
iceland
and greenland are there any bones in the
chichen itza
not there yes there are bones there but
no one has done that kind of analysis
on them and that would be that would be
uh that would be a great line of inquiry
and that would be definitive evidence
right of the type that i have not
presented
uh to you um that we could if we had
um there the skeletons in the cenote
are uh don't just they they
um there's they've date over the
centuries
but um yes if you did dna analysis on
them
um that that might give us an answer to
um
to this and so would finding something
like
the pin the bronze pin that i showed you
are there any references in the north
sagas
it seems like the kind of thing the
sagas would have recorded
if vikings made it all the way to mexico
maybe you know that's a that's a good
question about
what the sagas would have recorded and
um i was gonna say one of the historians
debate
the the use of the sagas
for um many years i was teaching with
anders winroth who's
now sadly left yale and gone to uh the
university of oslo and
he was consistently skeptical about
everything um in the saga so
the sagas don't report um on the vikings
going to
anywhere distinctively like the yucatan
peninsula anders was skeptical about the
descriptions even of their
going to um of locating finland in north
america
except for uh the site the site of
the atlanta meadows was so convincing um
to him and i agree with the comment
about
it would only be part of the saga if
they made it back and yes i think the
um if if the people i'm showing you were
norris
um presumably they are painted as
victims who are being drowned and then
they don't survive
right that's where we're seeing them
right before they die
valerie if i may ask a question so
haven't gyres
evolved and so were these predictions
that were made for the year thousand
so that's a very good question and um
i've done i've
looked at diagrams of the currents um in
different periods
but i i've my impression is that the
gyres are
the basic direction of the gyres is
pretty consistent
but i i one thing i like about talking
to this group is there are people here
who know more than i
so if you know speak up if you know more
than i do please
uh the driver going uh the current going
south
is actually is indicated to be
uh deep uh so that couldn't have helped
would that have helped the
the vikings go south on
i think well there there's a couple of
different
the there's the yes the blue line is
deep in the ocean but the red lines
um one of those crosses the yucatan
from so there's a a current that
crosses a lot of the atlantic and then
touches down
in um on the yucatan peninsula
but the red line was going north blue
line was going south
right basically
yes uh uh i was gonna say let's hold on
to that
if there's time at the end we can go
back and look at that slide yeah
uh valerie are you ready to continue yes
please go ahead
okay so now for part two of this talk
is about the pacific and here um
almost everything i'm talking about is
archaeological
and there is actually some dna studies
also
for for this regions and
some recent findings from published in
the summer
and so i'm just starting with a picture
of the pacific triangle
and the proposal that
and this is based on uh i think my next
slide will
yes uh that uh a um
an article uh from pnas by uh
janet wilmshurst proposing
two waves of migration so
one to the society islands
and then a second wave
to these remote islands between so to
these three
the three points on the triangle to
hawaii and then
rapid um to easter island or and to
um new zealand uh and this there's
um this analysis was done on the basis
of a careful examination of a lot of
carbon 14
samples and consciously
looking at smaller like plant lives like
leaves and twigs as opposed to charcoal
because
charcoal can live for a long time and
um the contention of janet wilmshurst
and her collaborators
was that uh the charcoal dates were
misleading because they
they suggested um a uh
the settlement of the islands several
hundred years before
the dates that she proposes
and um some of the information we have
about the settlement of the pacific is
very late from
when james cook and actually there are
some dutch voyagers
uh who travel in the 1600s and then
um james cook in the 1770s
uh and the these um paintings and
drawings
sketches give us a sense of the vessels
that the polynesians were using at the
time
um the polit here the voyagers are
wearing masks
the rowers are wearing masks this is
when they are coming out
to meet cook and this is some kind of a
ritual
that's why they're holding um this image
here
but the pictures show two
canoes um connected and then
uh a sale and the um
we know from this information from the
1700s to 1800s that the polynesians
could load a lot
of uh possessions including animals
onto the framework between the two
canoes as they were
crossing from one island to another we
don't know what kind of vessel
they were using um in the year 1000. i
think many
people think that they were using this
kind of vessel but we don't know that
there hasn't been any archaeological
evidence
of the kind of vessels that they used
um and then the uh some of the
information we have about how they did
this
comes from the late 20th century uh from
uh indigenous informants this is a man
named mao piolog
who had studied traditional polynesian
seafaring as a child and here he's
teaching it
to his children and
this allowed the polynesians they
basically
they they they did all their navigation
without any navigational instruments
this is also true of the vikings
um the vikings are going shorter
distances and they can see
in many cases they can see where they're
going
uh the um but the polynesians are orient
themselves by
looking at the sky looking at the
configuration of the stars of course it
varies
by the time of year it also varies by
your position in the pacific and so they
memorize
these various sets of stars that's what
mao was teaching here
and that allowed them to orient
themselves when they were in the ocean
and they were not near any land masses
and um the illustration
of this the power of this system of this
traditional system
was that mao was able to navigate
uh all the way from hawaii to tahiti
and his home he's
from the area around guam
so he's far from he's far from home
but in this voyage he he does this
voyage
for the first time and he navigates a
craft all the way from
hawaii to tahiti um using um
this set of knowledge that he's learned
from
his elders and so that i think is
again we don't know for sure how um
the polynesians navigated in this period
between 1200 and 1290
but it's very suggestive that there's a
traditional form of
navigation that allows them
that allowed them to cover this kind of
distances
um in the late 20th century things very
plausible
people that would have used it um
earlier
i was gonna say there's a funny story
about mao that he um near the uh
end of his life he uh is blown off
course and he's not two weeks late
coming home
and his family calls the coast guard
because they're concerned about him
coast guard
catches up with him and says basically
can we take you home and he said no no i
know exactly where i am
i've been in this storm i've been blown
off course
but leave me alone i'm going to get home
and he does he
he shakes them off so um the uh
the um dna report this was from the
summer
um and this was in nature and there's
some controversy about it this is where
i hope maybe somebody in the audience
can help me uh the the contribution
of the report is that um the
investigators looked not just at easter
island people have always thought easter
island would be the place where there
would be
the most contact between the likeliest
site of contact
between the polynesian islands and
the west coast of south america but
the these investigators looked also at
dna samples from
farther north from the marchesa islands
and
that's where if you were riding the
humboldt current
along the west coast going north
along the west coast of latin america
you would um arrive
north of far north of easter island much
closer to
the equator so they have a couple
of individuals whose dna shows
they say a specific moment of contact
probably around 1200 which matches
nicely with that
archaeological study um i told you about
of the
carbon 14 dates from the different
plants uh
and so they proposed that and then but
this i th it would be i think more
convincing if they had
ancient skeletons or pre-1492
skeletons um that or pre-1492
dna that allowed them that showed this
so far my understanding is that no
pre-1492 dna samples
have surfaced that show the mixing of
the native americans with or the native
latin americans
with the polynesians and there is some
criticism from
uh two uh other
investigators who are working on this
kind of eight movement of ancient
populations
and they're very skeptical about the
results
a part of this has to do with um who was
moving and whether the people who were
in latin america had a seafaring
tradition or a boat building tradition
that would have allowed them to go into
the pacific
or whether it's more likely that the
polynesians traveled all the way
from the marquesas or easter island to
latin america um and back and this also
raises
the ghost of um
tor heidel uh who was convinced that
um people had traveled from uh
latin america to the polynesian islands
but i was going to say that very few
people
were convinced by his i mean
i think everybody knew about contiki and
his voyages
but very few scholars were convinced
that the voyage
was possible i mean one of the
objections is that
when he uh did this uh reconstruction of
the voyage
um he he his raft was towed into um
off the coast for about 50 miles before
he began
the trip and
so that's i was going to say the
exploration of the pacific
there's another set of voyages by
these are the um speakers the so the
malayan languages were
related to polynesian and the
modern population of madagascar
speaks the malagasy language which is
related to
malay so there's linguistic evidence of
a connection between the malay peninsula
and madagascar there's also
cultivation of rice and southeast asian
crops
and that uh and then here um
you can see this other set of voyages
these took place actually before the
year 1000 they start around 500
and um they go across the
indian ocean and um
these have been demonstrated by careful
analysis
of the plants um in madagascar
versus the plants that are on the
african mainland and
the plants on madagascar have produced
many more much more evidence of the rice
diet
the only places on the african uh
mainland that have
comparable finds of rice are sea coast
of crc
ports and those are presumably where uh
people from asia merchants from asia
lived
so um that uh i was gonna say this is a
case where
really all of the evidence is either
archaeological
or ethno-historical as transmitted from
um you know it's used the either the
information from james cook
or the information from the late 20th
century uh
voyagers or the anthropologists who
studied with them
to reconstruct uh the void the mechanism
of the
the the navigation system the workings
ah now we get to our second break let's
thank you thanks so much um so i just
wanted to mention
uh the reason that we are muting
having videos muted is this is a
recorded
talk and we would otherwise have to
procure
individual um release forms from
everybody so thank you for your patience
and submitting your questions to the
chat
okay so uh someone had asked how did
navigators
such as pow carry enough food and water
and before you answer we had
uh professor stearns had said that water
and gourds
as coconuts and gathered from rain
falling on their
sails is i guess a possible answer food
both packed and caught their fish in the
water all the way
and their fluid can also be uh drunk
much
lower salinity than sea water so
about the transport of food and water
thank you i was gonna say the only thing
i would add to that is that i was i'm
reading about
uh tour hydrodoll today and when um
contiki was doing its voyage
the fish flying fish jumped up and
landed
on the raft they didn't even have to
fish for them
so uh the um
but uh yes i thank you um steve stearns
for you
for uh that concise answer
and anyone want to help me with the d at
my dna question about
uh the the reliability of of
um taking modern or 20th century dna
samples
and reading back proposing a single
event
occurring in 1200 whether that's
possible plausible or reliable
ah i have stunned i have stunned my
learned audience
plausible not terribly reliable
okay this is what has been offered in
the chat
oh it's funny you you've got more than i
do i don't oh i see i see
more from yeah uh yeah that was
that was my read um of the evidence and
i
think some of this has to do with what
we as historians know
about movement along the coasts and this
is one of the
objections to that report is that we
know for sure the polynesians are moving
all around the pacific
we don't have evidence of the coastal
peoples
in colombia and ecuador uh it's
sailing up and down the coast of uh
latin america we don't think
it's not even sure that they had
sailboats they they me they probably had
rafts
but it would have been very difficult to
go up and down and uh
i showed you those pictures from chichen
itza of the
gold items from costa rica and panama
those could easily have been carried
over land so um there's just not much
evidence of a lively
of a tradition of ocean travel on that
side
of on the western the west coast on the
northwest coast of uh south america
um so another suggestion in principle
reliable
uh depends on the contamination from
other biological sources
but dna sequences are quite
idiosyncratic
with low and calculable mutation rates
so another dimension to as an answer
that's that's very helpful um and uh
that's i um i need to learn more about
that so thank you very much for that
uh henry and then and new question yep
what about time keeping are there
similarities and how these peoples
in contact might have kept time
that's a very interesting question the
calendar is very important
and calendars move good calendars move
right people
are uh people in the past really want to
know
uh when is the right time to plant crops
or
when when eclipses are going to come
it's i write about
in my book that one of the uh big
questions
in east asia actually 1052 was about
people thought the end buddhists
believed that the end of the world was
coming and
there were some eclipse predictions and
people who could predict um accurate
eclipses
or almanacs that had good eclipse data
were extremely valuable and people went
to great lengths to try
um to import them i was going to say
also looking at the
q a that someone asked about um the
anthropology of the argonauts of the
western pacific since malinowski
no but i will thank you for the
suggestion
so should we go back to the last part of
the talk it's a uh i'll go
and it's about china and it's short
because as i told you there isn't too
much
science it's mostly uh historical
records
um so i just wanted to start with
a slide of this root
which was the main c corridor that was
in use before 1492 and
continued to be used after 1492 and it
connected
the ports of southeast china with
the um persian gulf ports especially
basra
which was the closest port um to baghdad
and also
you can see oman and the
um
we this there's a lot of chinese sources
that describe this route there's some
maps
of the region this is a
i wanted to just explain to you that the
reason the chinese are going there
is that they want to import these
different aromatics from southeast asia
and
aromatic is a catchword use the chinese
word is
meaning fragrant items
and the these include things like
sandalwood
they include spices um like
cloves uh they um there's some natural
products these aren't necessarily
aromatics but like the the feathers of
the kingfisher bird
um were uh the chinese valued very much
and
when i mean i tell you about these
things you can think oh well the chinese
were importing those they couldn't have
been that important
but the society uh in in china
and we know this from around the year
1000 and then
the use explodes in the next couple of
centuries
uh people are consumed with trying to
change the way that they smell
and the way that the air and their
houses smell uh and they burn a lot
of different kinds of incidents and
fragrant woods to try to change
their environment and
so those goods are the chinese are
importing in large quantities
and mostly from southeast asia but some
of them also come from india and come
from the arabian peninsula
the what the chinese are selling uh
they've got
ceramics this is a classic example
and so this is a slide from my teaching
about the iphone of the year 1000
the thing the item that everybody had to
have was
a high-fired um translucent
uh ceramic pot they were very easy to
clean and much easier to clean than
pots made in other parts of the world
that were not fired
um as high the chinese are also
exporting metals
uh ingots and in so ingots of copper and
tin
they're making metal objects like
cauldrons and walks and mirrors also
some weapons but we actually don't the
chinese are using a lot of those weapons
within china
we don't have much evidence of their
exporting them um and high quality
fabrics both cottons and silks and we
have
much more archaeological evidence about
the ceramics than we do
about um the other metals or the
textiles
and the main thing that the archaeology
tells us that the written records
don't is the quantity so we have
descriptions of ships leaving china
that are carrying ceramics but uh
we have archaeological sites one one
ship found
in indonesian waters one shipwreck found
in indian waters
has 600 000 pots
were found aboard on board it's just a
quantity that the written sources just
give no hint
of and
this we also have some shipwrecks the
actual ships
that survive uh this one is in a chinese
museum and uh it's interesting because
it has repair so you can see the chinese
made this with
planking like the vikings did right
they're different kinds of it's a
different construction but
um there's and then the chinese ships
had
distinct compartments my next slide will
make that clearer
ah no it won't sorry i cut that slide
because of time uh
the chinese ships had um distinct
compartments separate compartments
and those meant that they could that
question we had before about water
they could travel with a compartment
that was filled with fresh water
and they also sometimes uh traveled with
a compartment filled with seawater where
they had fish
um living in the water that they could
kill when they wanted to
but the the real advantage of those uh
discrete
uh compartments was that if the ship
sprang a leak
the the leak was contained in that one
area
and not in the hole it didn't affect the
whole ship
uh in my talk title i mentioned lidar
and um the contribution of lidar to
our understanding really of southeast
asia is
that and you can see here that this is
the same place
uh this top rome temple in angkor wat
and when you visit it you see all these
trees around it and it would be
it was very difficult for archaeologists
to know
um whether basically what the terrain
looked like what the surface looked like
because there was so much
undergrowth in this tropical forest
and here is a lidar picture
that so this is taken by bombarding
the ground with rays and then
editing them filtering them out and so
anything that bounces back from a plant
is filtered out
and so that archaeologists can see the
surface of the land and
the real surprise from angkor wat was
how many
of these what are now open spaces or
forested spaces historically contained
many many dwellings and the upshot is
that
encores what ankara was population
the estimate has been increased to about
750 000 people
which is far higher than what was
previously thought and there's
nothing like there there's no
information like that
in any of the written chinese sources
about cambodia
at this time
and then the um last slide of
the about the chinese is showing you
this route
that they traveled and the distances
that
they covered i mean in some ways the
i'm going to imply that the farther
people went with the
i mean the more impressive it was but in
fact
cutting directly across here saved
quite a lot of miles and then
the this route all the way from
guangzhou um to basra and then
down to safala south to safala
this is about three times the length of
columbus's voyages
so um i would say just in terms of the
distances that were traveled
some of the voyages that take place in
in what we conventionally call the age
of exploration
uh were not that much longer columbus's
voyages were
uh on on a par with those of the
millennial polynesians
um and actually shorter than those that
the chinese were traveling
as they went from and when i say the
chinese other people's indian
other peoples from the indian ocean are
also voyaging uh from
the islamic world and india towards
china
uh those um and so tagama's voyage you
know where he circumnavigates africa
even he is not going farther than the
chinese magellan yes
michelin goes around his crew he gets
killed right in a rebellion in
the philippines but magellan
circumnavigates the world
and so um and but i was gonna say the
reason
that we pay so much attention to the
later voyages is that
we know about their impact that they had
any
nearly immediate and far-reaching
consequences
there were many of the people living in
the americas
were killed by either the common cold or
flu
or smallpox and once
america had been emptied of the
indigenous of many of the indigenous
peoples
then european settlers and african
slaves
moved into the new world and there was
the creation of the triangle trade
so i mean that's a huge impact and
the voyages i'm talking about in the
year 1000 or around the year 1000
um the impact is not as immediate it's
not as obvious
but there they did affect
people who were living in different
regions
and so the vikings don't have much
impact on north america they pull out
after about 10 years
but they travel east um into
russia and ukraine this was in the this
was discussed in that article in the new
york times yesterday about the
dna and they um build
the first empires in
the ruse empire is
the product of vikings who have or
swedes who have come
mostly swedes people living in modern
sweden who have come
into modern day russia and ukraine and
create the ruse
state um the all of the pacific and
madagascar gets settled
by the polynesian voyages so that's very
clear
impact and the chinese economy
becomes very heavily intertwined with
that of southeast asia
uh so much so so so that
we have people who had been working the
land in china who
shift to working full-time in ceramics
factories
and we have forest peoples in southeast
asia who
um you know traditionally were hunting
and gathering
and they start to hunt to hunt and
gather full-time
um to for specific animals like those
kingfisher birds i told you about
that the chinese want so
um and the all of this economic activity
from and these connections that are
formed in the year 1000
contribute to the success
connecting up of the world in the
further connecting up of the world in
1500 i began by asking
or saying i was going to talk about the
historian's toolbox
and um i think the toolbox has changed
that
historians are have to look at dna
and ocean currents and lidar
and the residues of the chocolate
in ceramic vessels do i think historians
are going to give up documents
no i mean part of it is that we have
as we get closer in time to the present
we have so much more documentary
material
and and so much more coverage uh and
the documents have the great virtue all
the things i've been talking about
don't really they could they allow us to
see some of these changes
or to identify some of these changes but
um they
don't allow us to know
how anybody felt about anything or how
what the experience was like
and so the i think it's very important
as we
try to understand the history of the
whole world and all the different
regions of the world
that we use every technology we can to
reconstruct the past that's lost to us
but um but i think there's still
pleasures or insights to be pleasures
from studying insights to be
derived from studying these documents
documents
that at least so far these scientific
traces
uh and scientific testing techniques
don't allow us
to get at thank you very much
standing in as a proxy applause um
i will try to actually um
unmute everybody so that at the end they
can
give you a round of applause but uh i
think we can move
questions now uh so please go ahead and
start
um
okay uh first one have you looked at the
china porcelain trade to east africa
um a little bit there's there's a very
uh a very
fine scholar who works in that field
named john and who's
um french uh she's working in in in
france now
and uh and and the chinese have been
excavating
uh in east africa and so uh we can see
those fines have been um well published
uh we can see
the different kinds of pots that were
traded
that made it all the way to east africa
and um the
one of the things about chinese ceramics
and our there's a curator at the yale
art gallery named um denise laidy dr
denise lighty who's an expert in this
field
is that when chinese ceramic scholars
look at
a piece of a pot or the whole pot they
can tell which kiln it was made where it
was made
and so that's uh very helpful in terms
of
reconstructing um the sources of these
ceramics and figuring out
where they came from in china and then
how they traveled all the way to
east africa the chinese cartographic
tradition yes there is a chinese
cartographic tradition
uh the i mean it's a broad
generalization
i'd say that there's more maps of
domestic china than there are of uh
countries outside of
china but there are some and uh one of
the things the beinecke has a terrific
map of the chinese coast
that i've been um looking at
it's it's been scanned because of covid
and so
i have a color copy of it and uh the
uh should i read out these questions i'm
looking at these are from tim
weiskell about it or that'd be great for
the recording he asked about the chinese
porcelain trade to east africa
and the chinese cartographic tradition
and then gavin menges
um the author of a book called 1421
which i did not mention
um i have to say uh i don't know any
chinese
card-carrying chinese historian who
thinks that anything in 1421
is um believable so
uh and he claimed that he had
pre-columbian chinese maps
of the pacific but in fact he had
post-columbian maps or
you know he was using later maps and
then had a very convoluted argument
about how they you you could use these
his argument was these maps from
the 1500s were actually based on
information that was circulating before
1500 but any i think any serious
historian would say no
that information was not available
before 1500.
thank you our participant would like to
know what about the role of the indian
ocean currents
um for the uh sorry i just lost it do
you see it there
yeah for madagascar being populated by
the indonesians indonesians thank you
um it's funny it's they
they help and then of course the real
problem is that
it's very hard to sail from africa to
madagascar
that with the ocean currents it's so i
mean that's the real obstacle i mean it
seems so counterintuitive when you look
at a map
that the first people to get to
madagascar would have come from the
malay peninsula
and not from africa but that is indeed
the case and we know that
archaeologically because of this
evidence of the
from the of the many many different
plants and many multiple sites
uh where they found the evidence of the
rice and other asian crops on madagascar
and then a different set of more typical
african crops on africa
from one of our new frankie fellows when
you set out to write this book did you
know then
did you know then that you need to
expand your toolkit beyond text
and how did your method develop through
the course of your research to engage
different methods
such as archaeology lidar et cetera
uh thank you for the question the uh
i two of the maps i showed are from a
world history textbook that i
wrote co-wrote with my co-author's name
ken curtis
and when he and i started to write that
book i didn't
realize how important these other um
different these other methods these
scientific methods would be
uh and then as we were working on that
book and it took a
long time uh i've realized that you know
it was because for the world the mandate
of a world history textbook is
each part of the world gets its own
chapter right
you're not allowed to say oh i can't
write anything about southeast asia
because we don't know anything
you have to find out what we know so
that's when i started to
um expand my toolkit beyond texts and
i was always interested in archaeology i
i in high school i was interested in
archaeology and
actually my um earlier research i'm
interested
in uh excavated text so texts that
in the ground that archaeologists find
we have such a long transmitted
historical record from china
but we have very few texts that
um survive in the condition that they
were written in
and then we can look at them today and
those are the things that
i still find very compelling
and follow i'm just going to say one
more thing about
the research method is uh you know yale
is a great
place in so many ways but um i've just
found that if i
wanted to find out about uh different
kinds of technologies or science
technologies that i don't know about
that i could go talk to colleagues and
they would
very generously tell me what to read or
or explain things to me when i read what
when i did my reading and i still didn't
understand
they would patiently explain to me have
you followed the early dutch
cartographic history of south asia no
but i think it would be interesting you
know but the uh uh
i mean it's i was gonna say one of the
interesting things about
the post 1492 cartographic history is
how quickly the discoveries the
knowledge moves around the world
right once people have mapped the corr
the accurate outlines or even inaccurate
outlines that information is spreading
because everybody wants that information
so i had a related question um valerie
which is
you know what do you think having
studied these earlier voyages
what is distinctive about the encounters
you know the
the colonial encounters that happen
later on
is it just the scale is it because or
were there were these peoples when they
were moving and trading
did they try to conquer each other
already and we just don't know
and i'm just wondering you know the
colonial impulse right
um seems to have really come to the fore
in the you know 14 1500s later on
right and i was curious whether you
wondered
was there something different as you
said maybe is it because
there is information europe is then by
then
information transmission within europe
is very rapid
and uh things have really shifted in
europe by then
or that's part of the story
i was gonna say one of the things that
european historians talk about which i
think is very interesting
is the idea of a colony there's there's
a whole bunch of chinese historians who
would say oh when the chinese get
someplace new they don't have this
desire to form a colony and
that's that can be a very rosy view of
the chinese and they certainly
meddled in local politics and even
overthrew princes and replaced them
with their own candidates but they
didn't seem to have an idea that
you go to some place new that's if it's
continuous with china
then you can add it to china but if you
go to some place that's not contiguous
with china
they seem to just like leave it alone
they would like that the local ruler to
acknowledge the chinese ruler the
europeans have this
model of a colony and you know there's
roman colonies right
that goes way back but there um it's
been some very interesting work about
the crusades and the crusader colonies
in the mediterranean
so that's part of the answer is what's
going on in europe and
when the uh columbus gets to
hispaniola how he his first instinct is
to claim it for ferdinand and isabel
right he he's not where i think the
people i'm talking about
they might have landed but i don't think
their first impulse is to claim it for
any ruler um and then i think a key
factor
uh and especially significant today
thinking about covid is this the role
that disease played when the europeans
arrived in the americas and the
catastrophic consequences
it had on the local population right so
i see a comment on the chat
where you know colonialism is not an
artifact of european expansion
but you know the greeks and phoenicians
are also european incidentally
so they're giving me something and i and
i mentioned the romans too right
it's not um yes i agree colonialism is
not an artifact of european
expansion i think the interesting
question is where does it come from
where does it come from and when does it
start
right so because it's a point in time
where we can see
this kind of notion of um a colony
um develop and ripen
as it were right right and i think the
crusades have a lot to do with that
i mean the crusader states in the holy
land uh and then
when they're um forced to withdraw
when uh salad and defeats them and they
withdraw to cyprus
right that i that argument i find very
compelling about
the idea of colonies going back i mean
there are earlier precedents
but um that i think you can draw a
continuous line from
the crusader colonies in the
mediterranean to some of
its the um colonies in the atlantic like
madeira
uh or um the canary islands and then to
the americas thank you
i'm looking at the question we haven't
talked about slavery at all i have a lot
about slavery in the book
there's a lot of slavery it goes way
back in time i think it probably was
the norm um in almost every society
and um i i haven't i hope i haven't said
anything to imply that
uh that it didn't exist in the past it
it uh
was um right no no um i was wondering if
you could talk a little bit because you
do have quite a lot of it in the book
and
you know um wilkerson's new book
uh kind of tries to make the claim that
there's a particular way in which
slavery gets configured
that um you know goes back to um
1619 and the slaves african slaves
coming to
america and i was just curious because
in your book you do talk about the fact
that the notion of slaves
is around for a very long time right
um so we'd like to and more about um
from you i mean i think the
i haven't read wilkerson's book uh the
um to me the what's distinctive about
slavery in the americas after 1600
is the demographic change that the
the indigenous people have have been
wiped out to such a large extent
and that the population is replaced with
the african slaves
all of the examples i'm talking about uh
slaves are a source
of labor and also uh in in many cases
more importantly a source of children
there um there's a
the cambridge world history of slavery
volume two which is about the medieval
period
uh is about to come out and i was lucky
enough to see the page proofs
and the um in many societies around the
world
there are more women slaves than there
are male slaves
so that you know that and scholars of
slavery work on this
uh my colleague ed ragamer uh is one of
the people that
um they're aware of there's a lot of
variety for house in house slaves are
used
um in different places um i
in the year 1000 any society that
doesn't have enough goods to export
starts exporting either its people or
people it's captured
from its neighbors so it's just the the
world is short of labor and
everybody will pay money for so it's a
very appealing
commodity a grim grim as this is to us
today
a participant contributes the question
is not one of
colonies but one of frontiers a great
deal
is known uh sorry a great deal is known
about trading frontiers
i'm just pulling it up here
as a source of tension i think uh with
trading communities leading to new forms
of conquest
well i go back to what i said when
columbus lands on hispaniola he
already has an idea that he wants that
territory for
spain yes yes i mean so
you know there there's no there's no
prequel to that
his decision his his desire to somehow
claim that land
and there's a suggestion of a book that
looks very interesting
um commerce and cartography on colonial
frontiers
re-examining american and african
history through maps
which um i haven't looked at but i
definitely will
that sounds really interesting i'm
hooked because it says maps
there as well
are there any other questions please
feel free to type them in the chat
if not i might chime in and ask one more
question
so when you showed in the earliest part
of your talk about these independent
places where languages
are believed to have originated um
i say i know said um that you know
the harappan language is yet to be
deciphered right we don't know
and i wonder the fact that we have not
been able to decipher it having
disappeared the other ones
can that count as some kind of evidence
for independent
um generation
oh well i think could i mean there are
debates
there is there's a fascinating
discussion about the harappan script
and um basically
there are too many elements i think
there are about 400 elements in the
harappan script
so too many for an alphabet but too few
for a pictorial script
right right so that's very interesting
um you know is it uh
i i hate to say we're never going to
decipher it right you know that that may
be one of those
problems that somebody figures out
and and you know i mean i was going to
say the maya script
defied people for so long
and then you know this this kind of
basic
i mean i think there was a coincidence
of
certain kinds of information that people
had discounted
and then other people came along and
said oh you know what this is could be a
key
piece of information some reports from
um
spanish the spanish who had contact with
the meyer early on
and saw them writing and so uh that
information and then i think also this
key idea which came from i think knowing
about japanese that
you can write the same word in like five
different ways
right so a a a decipherer's nightmare
that the same word can be written in so
many ways um so
the anyway that's why you know i had the
harappan script in a different category
later i what i found really fascinating
to imagine
from reading your book and listening to
you to you today
was you know the imagination of what
these encounters when these people
showed up
like how did they even communicate with
each other
like how would that have looked like i
wonder if you
have sort of imagined and speculated and
what this might have been like
i mean i think the vinland sagas are
that give us
the best help on that because they
describe
uh people meeting and looking at what
each other
are carrying right and and and gesturing
to trade
uh and then there there's also that
great passage in the villain sagas where
there's an encounter between um a woman
uh uh a norse woman and a
um a local an indigenous woman
and the norse woman says you know my
name is i think it's goodred
and the local woman says oh my name is
gutrid and you think that's it makes no
sense and it does because she's just
repeating what she hears
right so that that would be the logical
thing you just when you start to work on
somebody's language
they say something you say it back and
then you start building up these
sentences so evidence that women were on
these voyages too
yes there is there and and there's some
archaeological evidence for
both the polynesians and the vikings the
viking evidence is we have that um a
needle sharpener
and also a weight that was used for um
as a to hold the yarn down when you were
spinning it
uh and we also in the saugus they talk
about women there's a
a woman who uh is uh quite feisty
and she bears she gets into a fight with
the local people and she bears her
breast and
slaps it with her a dagger and they all
run away
the source tells us appalled by her
behavior or terrified
by her behavior so and then for the
polynesians we know women are there
because
the polynesians multiply that you know
if it had been all men
they would have landed on the islands
and died after a certain amount of time
but they
they have children and and the
population gets going so
we know that women are on those voyages
too wow
i think there's another suggestion for
another book um
it's chocolate and choco canyon just a
coincidence
no no it's it's that's trade between
there's
sustained trade between um choco canyon
and the maya
we've got the chocolate going from the
maya north we also have i didn't mention
this because of time
macaw feathers so we have these brightly
colored
uh green and red feathers and um we've
got
feathered tapestries that have been
found that have these macaw feathers in
them that day to
around the year 1000 we also have sadly
bird cages
in which there are dead macaw skeletons
and the skeletons were
malnourished and they had as if they had
been kept inside
uh and not fed enough so there's
definitely a two-way trade
between choco canyon and
chichen itza any other questions
um
if not uh let's thank um valerie for a
fantastic
thought-provoking talk and i'll just i
think we should unmute everybody so that
we can
give her a round of applause